[Music]
one of the biggest names in the sport
they are female fighters in the world of
mixed martial arts are nothing new make
no mistake though it's still a man's
world but for one woman that wasn't a
reason to stay away swazey Valentine the
sports first cut woman as opposed to cut
man now works at the highest level of
mixed martial arts UFC the Ultimate
Fighting Championship we met up with her
at a UFC gym in White Plains New York
swazey Valentine is used to being the
lone female in a profession dominated by
men gosh I've been through a lot I've
dealt with assault physical assault
inside the cage by one of the coaches in
front of hundreds of people did you ever
find out why because I was a woman
they'll go right behind my back and be
like we don't want her we don't want her
how do you handle it I think to myself
I'm not gonna let anyone make me feel
like I don't deserve to be here bottom
line here is the UFC the Ultimate
Fighting Championship
the elite in mixed martial arts four and
a half years ago Swayze became the
promotion's first female cut man when
did you get the call from UFC oh I know
the day it was February 22nd 2014 right
that was incredible you can't get any
higher than that and the fact that I
made it there after everything that I've
been through I was so thankful that they
decided to take a chance on me
her job is a cut woman is to protect the
fighters hands before about then to stop
any bleeding once it's underway I have
45 seconds or less to get that fighter
to the next round because if for any
reason the doctor comes in and calls it
and says hey he's not good enough to
fight or she's not good enough to fight
right it's on me
she gonna mess up is she not gonna make
it she not fix that cut because it's a
she and not a he very possible
when Swayze decided she had to be a part
of MMA she knew she'd have to break down
some gender stereotypes so you decide
you need to have this as part of your
life what did you do so after that show
I went down I found someone I'm like hey
I really want to do something with your
show you know what can I do
I took a look at me goes why don't you
be a ring girl you did a couple days as
a ring girl right and thought what when
you were out there in front of the crowd
yeah it was not for me it was not for me
I mean that was too little clothes to me
in front of how many people I couldn't
do it but it was there in the cage that
Swayze found what she could do that's
where I saw like all the fighters and
the coaches and the fighters are getting
their hands raps and I'm like you know
what there's no greater honor in this
sport than to be the person to wrap that
fighters hand so we're gonna be going
into the MMA wrap knowing the what but
not the how Swayze googled MMA hand
wraps and found videos from legendary
cut man Jacobs stitch Duran I started
watching them and I'm like okay I'll
practice on myself and when I got a
little confident I found a local gym and
I just drove out there every day and
just asked hey can I wrap your fighters
hands for their sparring sessions and
how do you get them to trust you to do
this that was pretty hard
I just knew what my goal was and I just
kept practicing and every day that I
drive to the gym I'm like repeating my
hand okay four over the knuckles all
over the wrist 200,000 from determined
to confident Swayze slowly start
building her career in the amateur ranks
adding gyms and fighters all while
balancing two kids as a single mom it
took a lot of years a lot of free time
this definitely isn't a job that you do
for the money
I worked a lot of years for free was
thinking okay where can I go to really
expand and I thought Las Vegas it's the
fight capital of the world but getting
there from Washington State wasn't cheap
I didn't have a lot of money so I
donated my blood or my plasma and I'm
got money and I went to eight hours you
were donating blood and plasma so you
could afford to go do this thing that
wasn't gonna make you a lot of money
anyway why I don't have an answer for
what drove me to do it I just had this
deep burning gut desire of like it's
gonna work out just keep going just keep
going Swayze's gut was right all that
sacrifice paid off when she got that
first call from the UFC
can you explain what it's like during a
fight oh it's really actually
indescribable I'm excited I'm nervous I
get most comfortable when I finally sit
down and I get my sheet and it shows who
I'm gonna rap and then I go in there and
when I meet the fighter I shake
everyone's hand and that like totally
brings me down the bigger stage for
Swayze is still not enough to pay the
bills so she works at her local post
office six days a week comp and vacation
time allows her to take off for UFC
matches did all your fellow employees
know what you do in your spare time they
do what do they think they love it on
the outside they're just like oh my gosh
it's so dangerous like are you okay are
you safe and I'm like absolutely so
they're super proud of me and they love
hearing like what am i next show how did
it go so they're super supportive and
that support is something Swayze passes
along simply by being that lone female
face what message do you have to some
little girl who sees you out there that
says well there's only one I don't know
if I could do that well now I know after
being the first that there are many more
women following my path already and I
just hope that any little girl that sees
that too shows that hey you can achieve
your dreams whether it's your first or
the 15th or the 30th you do what you
want to do and love every second of it
Swayze's next UFC event is on November
17th in Argentina and there were some
men along
wake up men that sort of took her under
the wing and taught her tricks of the
trade that you had to know to do it but
that was just determination that got her
there you know she loves it six days a
week and still the smile on her face
from ear to ear a job that doesn't pay
man or woman you want a definition for
passions he Swayze but there it is